et bien bonjour bienvenue dans ce
diagonale la leçon bonjour jean luc
bonjour stéphane alors aujourd'hui une
spéciale la leçon sur les maths
élémentaire on va dire que j'ai pas
beaucoup de maths élémentaires en fait
non il y en a pas beaucoup aux échecs
donc bon évidemment il ya les fameux mat
avec deux dames donc pour les débutants
qui qui poussent leurs pions madame
trois hommes cadres des autres à outreau
d'amsterdam
c'est plus dur parce qu'on risque de
faire patte dans ce cas là exactement
donc bon on verra lundi aux débutants
d'échanger toutes les pièces à dire des
deux dames
ensuite il ya les maths avec deux dames
deux tours
une dame est aujourd'hui je crois que
nous avons nous allons nous intéresser
aux maths avec une tour et aux maths
avec deux fous voilà donc selim intérim
en terre qu'il faut connaître l'histoire
et le matériel presque minimale pour
gagner une tour pour mater face aux
rovers
ou alors de fou il ya aussi un autre m'a
tellement terme et qui est beaucoup plus
technique qui nourrit une leçon complète
qui est le match fou et cavaliers on
peut aussi materic fouet cavaliers et à
savoir qu'on ne peut pas à mater avec
deux cavaliers oui on ne peut pas voter
avec deux cavaliers ça c'est quelque
chose qu'on expliquera d'ailleurs pour
leurs parents elles sont fous et
cavaliers est donc faux et cavaliers là
ça commence à devenir un petit peu plus
compliqué il faut savoir quand même
qu'il ya des joueurs amateurs qui ont
déjà pas mal d'expérience mais qui
n'arrive pas qu'ils ne savent pas
comment mater avec fouille cavaliers
hormis deux évidemment remettant dans
cette émission la vie sur fou et
cavaliers quand même enfin sur par dance
2 cavaliers on peut pas maté sauf si un
pion voilà c'est encore un pion parce
qu'il ya une petite astuce et ça on vous
invite à aller voir cette émission le
mat avec deux cavaliers un pion ça ça
vaut le coup ouais c'est très technique
il s'arrête jamais en compétition ça
arrive dans vraiment très très rarement
est très très rarement alors on va voir
le plus élémentaire des maths peut-être
ce par quoi il faut commencer à prendre
nos échecs
parce que si on sait pas mater avec roy
et tour elle et on aura beaucoup de mal
à gagner une partie parce que c'est
quand même le matin connaître c'est
souvent c'est très souvent compétition
une partie peut se terminer par un tour
contre euro oui non oui c'est
indispensable de savoir mater avec une
tour de toute façon je crois que c'est
la première étape pour devenir un bon
joueur de club c'est de savoir quand
même hâte et avec avec une tour c'est
comme important de de bien maîtriser ce
match surtout pour les parties rapides
aussi puisque c'est vrai que quand on
n'a plus beaucoup de temps on quand on
fait des blitz et qu'on se retrouve avec
une tour c'est c'est bien de connaître
la technique la plus rapide pour mater à
l'or noir tout de suite un premier
première position justement pour
illustrer ce fameux maintenant voilà on
a choisi cette position qui est la plus
défavorable presque pour les pour les
blancs puisque leurs ouailles à tour
sont extrêmement excentrée alors que le
roi noir lui-même est très bien placé au
centre ville et alors ce qu'il faut
comprendre peut-être déjà fort bien ce
qu'il vaut bien visualiser aux échecs
peut-être on le voit peut-être bien dans
cette finale la plus que la position des
pièces elles mêmes ce sont les casques
contrôler les pièces et or alors que la
caractéristique de la tour qui va être
essentiel dans cette finale c'est que la
tour aussi féru fait contrôler les
grandes traverse et les grandes colonnes
donc en fait elles contrôlent tout ça ce
qui fait que cette tour est susceptible
d'en fermer progressivement le roi
adverse et si elle s'approchait d'une
case en diagonale comme ça elle peut pas
évidemment mais est bien le l'espace
droit devant eux on voit diminue voilà l
idée cette poussée comme ça ou un noir
un petit peu sur un gwenn ont en tout
cas sur une rangée
voilà exactement donc je veux juste te
montrer exactement donc le
le concept hyper important donc avec
cette tour ou si on peut enlever les
flèches donc la chose principale à
retenir c'est donc de pousser le roi
vers ce que l'on appelle la bande de
l'échiquier donc la bande de l'échiquier
se voit ici par le maître parole sur la
case des 8 et il sera donc prisonnier
donc hip hop offert le roi 1 pour le
maître prisonniers sur les caisses des 8
il faut tout simplement avoir une tour
sur la septième rangée tour qui serait
ici est qui et qui le qui l'empêcherait
de bouger qui pourrait pas ils
pourraient pas sortir il serait contrôlé
par la tour exactement
donc la bande à l'échiquier ces îles
habitées manger mais c'est aussi la
première rangée donc tout à gauche c'est
tout tout ce qui est le coin de chiper
on va juste coloré tout ça voilà c'est
donc tout ça c'est trop voilà donc c'est
tout ça tout ça c'est la bande de
l'échiquier très très important alors
voilà alors on va voir dans cette leçon
non seulement évidemment le le matin le
vrai tour mais le net le plus rapide
dans le match le plus rapide qui permet
avec le roi et la tour de bloquer au
maximum le roi adverse et d'aller plus
vite possible il ya d'autres techniques
qui sont possibles et qu'ils sont
beaucoup plus longues que celles qu'on
va vous montrer là qui est la plus
rapide
bref alors eh bien première étape tout
de suite d'abord ces bombes et cécile et
blanc qui vont jouer
la première étape c'est déjà de
restreignent tout de suite le
l'espace du roi noir en mettant la tour
entre le roi blanc ici et au renoir on
la met au milieu parce qu'on va avoir
besoin quand même du roi qui va être
obligatoire pour protéger la tour et
aider à ce que la tour restreignent
l'espace l'on voit ici que déjà bien
suite à ce premier coup il est tout
simplement contrôler cette traverse et
bien leur one man is his eyes et ne peut
plus jamais allées de ce côté là et on
va faire en sorte qu'il ne pourra jamais
jamais jamais jamais plus on est dans le
c'est clair il a déjà avec ce coup tours
1 1 on a fait ce que l'on appelle des
limites et un une zone dans laquelle le
roi le roi noir ne peut pas échapper
donc là il est dans la gauche de
l'échiquier à tout ça est interdit tout
ça est interdite et maintenant il va
falloir réduire cette zone jusqu'au
matin voilà je peux montrer toutes les
cases comme ça voilà tout ça est
interdit maintenant on en est même le
cycle est là donc on voit très bien que
le l'espace du roi noir est complètement
réduit grâce à l'action de cette tour
alors coup suivant mais les rois et en
général ils cherchent à rester au centre
puisque c'est là où il n'est plus le
plus le plus dynamique
moi et puis c'est la wii ne se fera pas
mater avec lui sera plus tu as de la
chance ils essayent de rester au centre
on pourra pas le matéos entier sur voilà
alors les blancs et en ont besoin bien
que le roi maintenant se centralise
parce que sans le roi la tour elle même
comme la tour tout est reprise par le
roi adverse sans problème eh bien il
faut que le roi blanc aide à la
protection de cette tour pour aider à
l'enfermement alors deuxième groupe
simplement pour la centralisation du roi
blanc c'est assez simple je crois qu'il
ya pas grand chose à dire là dessus oui
une chose importante aussi c'est qu'on
ne met pas avec avec une tour on ne met
pas le roi adverse uniquement avec la
tour voilà donc il faut deux pièces il
faut le roi et la tour donc le roi blanc
doit se rapprocher du roi adverse pour
le maté maintenant le roi adverse et
bien jouent toujours au centre pour
l'instant il attend est attendu à toi de
jouer
alors noté qu' à la fin de ce mois
comme qui s'applique
mais aux échecs il faut il faut mater
l'adversaire en moins de 50 coups sans
coût de pions donc là y'a plus de pions
licence échange de pièces là aucune
pièce ne peut être échangée puisque si
on perd la tour la partie est forcément
nul
tout à fait alors coup suivant et bien
continuer à rapprocher le roi voilà 23
alors toujours le roi noir continue son
petit mouvement d'attentes et maintenant
ça y est on à restreindre
enfin l'espace même je dirais on
traverse exactement on va on va
commencer à réduire le l'étau donc au
tour du roi est donc bon là on va
peut-être pas mettre des cases rouges
comme tout à l'heure mais ces délits la
forêt de plus en plus peut-être on
pourrait le faire mais en tête montrer
les cases qui sont disponibles peut être
plutôt que les verts sont retirés seront
moins nombreuses donc voilà coup suivant
le coup d'état est possible on se
rapproche des ouragans mais le roi blanc
mettant ici et bien protège donc c'est
impossible pour le roi noir ici de
baladeurs tout à fait n'aura pas donc la
tour est extrêmement bien protégés et
l'homme et n'envoie que ce roi ici du
fait de l'action de la tour sur ses
colonnes et bien n'a plus comme classes
disponibles que ce petit espace qui est
déjà beaucoup plus réduit déjà le roi ne
peut plus faire son mouvement de
balancier il peut plus revenir ici et ça
y est il est obligé de céder un peu de
terrain
ouais le renoir qui n'a plus que le
quart de l'échiquier donc ce qui est
déjà la moitié de tout à l'heure en
trois coups simples oui donc maintenant
son espace va se réduire de plus en plus
de plus en plus vite alors faut jouer
pour les noirs donc il faut déjà mais il
est obligé de céder un peu de terrain et
maintenant il faut que les blancs et
bien continuent leur avancée alors pour
l'instant la tour ne peut pas gagner de
traverses puisque là elle serait en
prison simplement donc il faut
manoeuvrer un peu avec le roi encore il
faut se rapprocher des héros adverses
c'est ce qui est fait par le coup droit
ou 3 il faut contourner la tour qui pour
l'instant
évidemment le convie des halles pour les
blocs s'arrêter de jouer roi ici mais
bon la tour jeanne 1 on peut pas prendre
sa tour quand même sacrément puis ce
serait mal venu
non je pense que la grèce ça sera très
content si on prenait simplement
l'exemple quand donc le roi noir lui en
profite pour revenir au centre mais
maintenant suite aux coups droits des
trois on va voir que la après si les
noirs joué le coup ici roi des six et
bien maintenant le roi blanc pourrait
pénétrer dans le camp adverse par
exemple sur cette case
il pourrait venir en c4 est contrôlée
dans ce rôle et ses cases el mouataz et
restreindre l'espace du roi noir donc
les c'est pourquoi les noirs jouent
plutôt le coup droit ses cinq ici comme
ça je bloque toujours ton droit mais
maintenant le roi s'étant rapprochés on
peut gagner une colonne alors comme on a
vu pour l'instant c'est cette colle au
delà qui est contrôlé et bien on va
gagner encore un peu de terrain
hop et on va faire un petit bilan au
regard des contrôles ici et donc les
cases regarder se réduisent donc on veut
gagner on vient de gagner le contrôle de
quatre cases supplémentaires voilà
l'état de 15 qui sont sur la colonne des
tout à fait mais bien vu bien vu jean
luc effectivement c'est ce sont ces ces
quatre cases ici que je marque en jaune
on essayait de me sens d'ailleurs il
faut montrer donc il faut montrer que
ces manoeuvres se permettent donc de
gagner du terrain et c'est bien le
maître du jaune par exemple pour bien
comprendre
la nuance entre tout à l'heure et
maintenant voilà alors les clés noires
ayant compris la manoeuvre
ils ont compris que maintenant si les
allées sur cette case ici ici là sur
cette case b5 et bien les blancs
pourraient encore avec cette tour gagner
encore une case ici gagner encore une
colonne sur ici gagner encore cette
colonne là donc ils ont compris donc il
joue plutôt moi c'est 6 à 10 ans ont
battu mahut de ce côté là mais je vais
essayer de partir de l'autre côté oui
mais attention maintenant c'est le roi
qui joue son rôle avec le très joli coup
hop roi c4 qui maintenant enlève et bien
ces fameuses cases ici de plus voyez
aura cette aide qui a un coût important
encore une fois puisque il reprend la
règle qu'on utilise pour relater avec
une dame
c'est à dire la fameuse règle de
l'opposition mais les rois là en face de
l'autre leroy c 4 en face du roi c6 donc
on voit que ce roi c4 finalement
en étant en juste en face du roi adverse
donc là on va crise est un peu tendu un
petit peu de couleurs d'ailleurs en
étant le roi ans et quatre en face du
roi c6 on voit qu'ils permettent de
contrôler ces trois cases des trois
cases en jaune oui ça s'appelle prendre
l'opposition voilà et finalement il
empêche le roi c'est 6 de venir sur la
cinquième rang j'ai donc finalement
seront sekkat joue le rôle d'une tour à
lui tout seul tout à fait alors tout à
fait c'est exactement ça c'est le roi
qui remplace effectivement une tour et
qui profite du fait que les rois ne
peuvent pas s'approcher l'autre
puisqu'ils se mettra en échec les
agréments et pas de règles particulières
ont fait que les robots peuvent pas se
toucher
si simplement qu'ils se mettent en échec
et ça c'est interdit ces interviews
rocks alors roy v6 ou normal on essaie
d'éviter que laurent blanc ne prenne
encore plus d'espacé on avait reculé en
b 7 dans ses sets et laurent blanc est
encore montée d'un cran et maintenant au
coût peut-être un peu plus punchy que ce
qu'on a vu jusqu'à présent parce qu'on
pourrait dire mais je peux gagner une
traverse ici en contrôlant cette colonne
oui mais on peut faire encore plus loin
par une petite astuce qu'il est bon de
savoir quand le roi est proche du bord
on peut aller encore plus loin
ici en d6 faisant un échec et on voit
que la les noirs n'ont plus beaucoup de
choix cases disponibles ici ou là et on
va voir tout de suite que les rois les
rois les noirs choisissent le cours a
baissé alors pourquoi re 17 et pas
plutôt le coup droit à 5 qu'on va
montrer tout de suite on en croit cinq
paires directement puisque la tour qui
est sur la case des six pourraient tout
simplement attendre la cie sur la
sixième rang j'ai donc je voudrais tour
ses 6,5 ou d'atteinte
par exemple si et le roi noir n'a qu'une
seule canne c'est la case à 4 d'ici peu
parlé sur cette case ni sur ses raisons
ni sur celle là ni sur salon vakili
complètement fermée on le voit bien
c'est très clair là dessus donc roi à 4
seul coup toutes les espèces sont
contrôlés et là on voit qu'il ya la
fameuse opposition avec les trois cases
contrôle et donc le roi blanc joue le
rôle d'une tour à la tour blanche de
jouer également le rôle d'une tour en
jouant tour à 6 finalement 3-6 c'est le
coup
qui finit la partie échec et mat voilà
là nous avons échec et mat donc leur one
le roi ne peut pas les la vie dans la
cause de la tour il est en échec
il peut pas aller là on peut pas aller
là il peut pas aller là qui est contrôlé
par le roi est ici est toujours en échec
par la tour donc échec et mat voilà donc
la position la plus importante de ce
match donc roi et tour contre roye donc
c'est pourquoi ensuite assez d'échecs et
bien et noir reviennent en baisse est
plutôt est là et bien les blancs
continuent l'avancé mais non de
l'endroit qui est un peu éloigné donc il
faut le ramener toujours pas oublier que
le roi doit être proche de sa tour et
attaquer leurs adverses évidemment on
prend une position toujours c'est
beaucoup mieux mieux de prendre
l'opposition
on va le voir parce qu'après roi c'est
cette idée on regarde l'opposition et
maintenant le roi noir est obligé encore
une fois de reculer alors il va aller
par exemple ans baissaient en 17
et maintenant on peut continuer notre
manoeuvre tranquille up échec toujours
pareil si le roi vient ici on a la même
technique que combien de voir mais en
étant en étant un cours éclate on attend
avec la tour laura bush et ben hermans
et ses échecs et mat sur a7 donc il faut
partir encore loin et ça y est on a on a
bouché le roi ça y est sur la dernière
en générant la visite de leur laisse
j'ai le droit et sur la bande de
l'échiquier il reste plus qu'à passer à
la dernière étape c'est-à-dire
rapprocher le roi encore voici six jours
une opposition c'est toujours mieux
voilà tout à fait et maintenant il ya
plusieurs possibilités on peut faire un
échec puisque ont encore un échec on
retrouverait le même match avec croit
ici il assure une aide bande de
l'échiquier et on voudrait ici et
ensuite aux frais maths mais préfère mon
truc tout la technique que je devrais
traditionnel peut-être oui
enfin je sais pas si les traditionnels
plantes comme aussi celles que j'ai
connu un petit c'est la technique
basique dans les blattes - tout
simplement et le roi noir on l'a vu ne
peut pas se mettre en opposition sous
peine de maths
voilà pourquoi je suit échec et mat donc
le roi doit venir en huit ans qu'il est
vraiment de ça y est on l'a repoussé
dans le coin complet
ça y est là il suffit de suivre tout
simplement voilà maintenant tu dois y
aller chez le roi en face il faut faire
revenir mais non et voilà ça y est c'est
le fameux matt ans la superbe tour et je
suit imparable et en seize coups se sont
quasiment je crois que le match retour
est roi je crois qu'effectivement ça
d'autres 16 ou 17 coût maximum oui dans
le pire des scénarios bon on peut quand
même accordé une vingtaine de coups on
peut accorder 25 ou donc aux
débrouillards tromper bien sûr on a
droit de se tromper mais normalement on
doit y arriver si on si on fait pas
d'erreur ah oui à une vingtaine de coups
maximum on fait chaque et m'a donc on
voit que la règle des 50 coups est
largement suffisant ce qu'on attend de
faire au moins deux fois matt donc même
si on se trompe complètement mais il
reprendre tout à zéro
on pourrait encore faire maths voilà
donc la règle de l'opposition lemaitre
le roi sur la bande et bons conseils
pour pour les téléspectateurs c'est tout
simplement de s'entraîner d'essayer avec
leurs amis cette position et jusqu'à ce
qu'il maîtrise parfaitement le matin
avec une tour voilà donc on va ensuite
on va revenir ensuite à une autre
position classique qu'on va voir tout de
suite si on peut la montre et de ceux de
ce fameux match voilà une petite de
position qu'on voit déjà qu'il ya il ya
la fameuse opposition tomine paris
évidemment c'est une position très
favorable puisque le roi gras et déjà
sur la bande était très curieuse cette
position parce qu'en fait il ya un très
grand nombre de coups pour les blancs
qui gagne fait qu'ils font en maths en
3 tout à fait voilà très grand grand
nombre de courriers en fait c'est
n'importe quel type de deux coups pour
la tour en fait on peut jouer tous les
tous les coups que l'on veut avec la
tour et ça fait maintenant trois coups
donc en fait il n'y a pas de match avec
un coup forcé mais toute une panoplie de
coups tous les coups de lettres or gagne
on va tout simplement à montrer un bien
par exemple tour des uns pourrait jouer
en d4 on pourrait jouer n'importe où il
vous ferez le test vous pourrez aussi le
jouer sur le côté vous pourrez jouer
votre tour sur n'importe quelle des
cases qui étaient disponibles
le roi noir bouger maintenant on
retrouve le fameux nat qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure il suffit dans le péché le roi
noir de s'échapper trop loin et il faut
s'empêcher voir monsieur renard de
partir sur la colonne f
donc je te laisse sur chaque coup et
bien tout simplement et je crois que là
et bien voilà tour f1 tout sa flore
pourquoi parce qu'il était dans cette
tour joue sa fameuse colonne de contrôle
on voit que laurent blanc lui joue sa
fameuse traverse le contrôle et le roi
noir n'a plus beaucoup de cases
il est obligé de revenir en opposition
donc il le joue est obligé il n'a pas
d'autres coûts et là le fameux
maintenant un coup donc et le fameux
matt tôt la fuite le tableau de match
classique toujours la tour sur la
dernière haie chez tourcoing et si le
roi qui contrôle très bien toutes les
cases de fuites sur la traverse sur la
7ème traverse donc voilà intéressant il
faut il faut connaître cette position
elle est amusante elle et elle est
connue elle est connue c'est un petit
problème en trois coups en général dans
les problèmes on cherche le coup qui
gagne mais là il ya beaucoup de kouqian
puisque alors c'est un peu le paradoxe
de cette position cercle joueur qui est
habitué à trouver le coup qui gagne il
est un peu coincé parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de coups qui gagne alors du
coup ils se demandent où est l'astuce
ouais on est l'astuce c'est simplement
donc d'attendre que le roi noir fasse
son choix et après de l'enfermer donc
contre la bande tout simplement voilà
donc on a vu ici les maths le mat roi
tour contre roye ce qu'on a tout vu je
crois que la technique elle est complète
on l'a bien expliqué évidemment ce qu'on
vous conseille c'est de vous entraîner
on va conseiller aux secrétaires au
téléspectateur lui c'est de s'entraîner
et en plus s'entraîner face à un
ordinateur je crois c'est le menu on
peut s'entraîner face à l'ordinateur
parce que on peut rentrer la position
qu'on veut contre l'ordinateur
l'ordinateur ne se vexe pas garanti la
bataille a fait un bon côté l'épicier si
par mégarde on l'est à tour en prison
peut toujours revenir en arrière
exactement c'est pas interdit contre
l'ordinateur on peut être contre un
joueur avec un arbitre en terminant on
peut afficher votre ordinateur
on peut tricher voilà à tout casser on
peut aussi s'entraîner tout seul je
crois que même moi personnellement j'ai
fait beaucoup de partir tout seul fait
des petits quand on a appris aussi
chargé j'ai essayé seimat jusqu'à
arriver à maîtriser complètement la
technique mais c'est bien de s'entraîner
de bien comprendre les mécanismes mais
bon ça rentre assez assez facilement
mais c'est essentiellement de savoir
matt est d'autant plus qu'après ces
schémas de maths vont même se retrouver
en milieu de jeu parfois c'est à dire
que le fait de le que le roi soit
coincés sur une bande et qu'un seul
échec de traverses permettent de le
faire mal on arrive même fréquemment
dans les dents les parties c'est ce
qu'on appelle là bas du couloir
d'ailleurs ça va du pouvoir mais qui est
pas forcément sur la huitième il peut il
peut aussi se passer au milieu de
l'échiquier demandant que le roi est
pris dans un couloir
je dirais un peu
comment dirais je l'appelle et trois
naturels quoi voilà artificielle quoi un
couloir artificielle couloir fabriqués
par l'adversaire alors on va passer tout
de suite à notre deuxième matelly
mentaires de ce jour donc on vous l'a
dit il ya un troisième la télé mentaires
qui est celui de fouet cavaliers il a
ici s'agit du mat avec avec deux fous
mais en fait on a montré on a choisi de
mettre cette même le sont parce que
c'est peu ou prou le même principe on va
dire sauf qu'au lieu de fonctionner sur
évidemment des traverses qui sont
l'apanage des tours on va fonctionner
sur les diagonales et on a besoin de
complémentarité des fous pour contrôler
la fois les quinze mois et les cases
blanches alors on va voir tout de suite
dans cette position eh bien pourquoi il
s'agit du même principe est bien en
contrôlant ici cette grande diagonale on
voit très bien et bien qu'on enferme
seront ici de ce côté-là de l'échiquier
voilà il peut pas il pourra pas passer
ce mur on pourra se balader que sur cet
espace vital qui est déjà assez grand
mais qui qui quand même déjà restreint
et iront à voir qu'on a aussi besoin du
roi pour arriver à mater la nation on va
voir ça assez vite parce que c'est à peu
près le même principe c'est même presque
plus facile à des deux fous
oui c'est un petit peu plus facile alors
bon une note importante c'est que nous
là il faut plus parler de deux
rectangles mais plutôt de triangle ça
veut dire que dans classe que tu as
d'expliquer que c'est que le roi noir
dont il est finalement il est
il est enfermé dans le triangle gauche
oui on peut parler de ce deuil d'une
sorte de triangle voilà et il va falloir
réduire ce triangle donc c'est assez
simple toujours le même principe savez
un triangle droit qui avec un bel angle
droit acquis
on va donc on va jouer d'abord le
premier coup pour les barbus simplement
voilà c'est un peu comme avec la tour et
bien au lieu de gagner une traverse est
longue diagonale
voilà ça y est tout de suite voyez on
voit que on a gagné on a gagné toutes
ses diagonales là en fait exactement là
le triangle ou la cire est rassuré rond
et on parle donc de petits triangles de
moyens triangle et de grand triangle à
le triangle devient de plus en plus
petits
lorsqu'on a envie de faire cesser
d'aller sans doute ici par exemple mais
le fou ou peut-être par la nuit après
par la main tout cas d'effectivement de
gagner comme ça petit à petit des des
diagonales alors passé 5
évidemment là alors on pourrait jouer le
coup ici échec mais c'est un autre coup
qui a été choisie qui est pas mal aussi
mais attention fois là bas c'est une
erreur oui ça va vers le tout à fait
bien sûr très important fois l'appareil
est une erreur puisque sur foix iii le
roi noir bien sûr la casse des 4 et
sortent du triangle de sortir et du
triangle tout à fait donc c'est pas
possible
donc c'est très important c'est qu'il
faut que le roi il faut que le roi blanc
complète les cases du triangle
alors il faut d'abord empêché le roi
noir évidemment la gravière chatouiller
les fous parce qu'ici il réchappe où il
est fou avec avantage avec les fous
c'est qu'ils se protègent joignait ici
pouf le roi noir ne pourra pas passer
puisque les fous contrôle très bien donc
deux fous comme ça ne peuvent pas être
attaqué par un roi donc on a on a bloqué
on a gagné en fait une talonnade de
l'autre côté c'est à dire qu'on avait
gagné de ce côté là
maintenant on gagne de ce côté aussi
envoyé blanche et noire on va voir
ensuite c'est assez facile loin des six
hommes on gagne encore une diagonale
voilà on en profite du fait que
mais cette case là est interdite par le
fourrier la complémentarité des fous moi
c'est 6 et bien en bloc tout de suite
pour empêcher le roi noir de partir et
on a bloqué ici encore c'est diego n'a
donc oui on peut même d'égalité des
diagonales sans le roi jusqu'à présent
mais là il a on a besoin du roi puisque
le roi est au contact des fonds on peut
plus bouger les foules donc il faut
bouger le roi donc très bien ressaisi
ensuite on avance le roi et on va voir
que mais non ça va aller très vite 3c
set up on gagne encore une diagonale on
profite du fait que le foot contrôle
très bien les cases noires et ici ça y
est voilà tout est contrôlé ici par le
roi est ici par les fous mais on voit
bien la complémentarité des pièces voilà
il priait tension clary presque
maintenant je ne parle même plus de
diagonale voilà le roi avance trois des
huit échecs
maintenant il peut pas partir évidemment
à cause du fou ça il peut pas sortir
on a bien fait attention qui ne sortait
pas du triangle c'est le mater est très
proche mais que le roi n'a plus d'espacé
quitter chaque encore voilà ça y est la
plus de deux cases le roi donc
maintenant le mater est facile il est
évident il faisait envoyer quand c'est
encore plus rapide qu'avec la tow
olympus quand je pas en quoi on dit coup
ça y est on a mis le roi sur le coin
optique ou d'attentes 3,8
on ramène le roi le roi noir n'a pas le
choix il doit jouer forcément mes 8 ans
suit ici
roye b 6 on voit bien que cette case est
contrôlée nokia pas le choix et
maintenant c'est maintenant 2 voilà donc
mais cet échec ou échec à l'endroit des
8 et voilà et le fait d'appeler le match
très facile voilà donc c'est la même
technique on en est le roi sur le côté
c'est même plus facile on voit qu'on l'a
fait en caisse coup bras c'est un peu
pareil avec la tour on a fait 16 tout à
l'heure mais ça peut être un peu plus
lent mais c'est quand même un peu un peu
peut-être presque un peu plus facile
avec les fous oui tout à fait pas et
bien terminée pour s'ébattent
élémentaires qu'on vous invite à
réfléchir à revoir à travailler chez
vous et on vous donne et bien rendez
vous pour une prochaine leçon sur leonel
télé voilà à bientôt